Oh ouais, c'est comme ça, alors fais-le
amis qui aiment dire wow
les youtubeurs
Salut
jamais ressenti
toi
[Musique]
un patron a déjà abandonné
terbesit Puits pour créer du contenu
atelier parce que je le fais tous les jours
dans l'atelier et même alors pas facile
beaucoup de lutte à traverser de
appareils qui n'ont pas assez de mémoire
Ian le processus de téléchargement est très compliqué
où le réseau de notre village est très
limité puis gadgets ou
les appareils que nous utilisons aussi encore
vraiment vieux
[Musique]
parce que tout le monde n'a pas la mode
sur YouTube et 33 personnes ont été sélectionnées
vraiment je m'entraine intensément salut
puis dans leurs six mois
ont déjà des revenus et réussissent
monétiser chacun de ses comptes YouTube
[Musique]
Je veux que mon village soit cool
il vaut mieux avoir la source
revenu inattendu
soit par le gouvernement, soit par
nos aînés puis par valeur
meilleure économie pour les enfants
mon petit-fils vivra avec une bourse
il reste confortable n'est plus épinglé
comme le village le plus pauvre vivant